[Music]
major developments out of Iraq this hour
where the Prime Minister says he's
resigning Adel Abdul Marty's
announcement comes after one of the most
violent days since anti-government
protests began two months ago more than
50 people were killed on Thursday the
curfew in Masseria has been lifted for
families to hold funerals the UN has
called for an investigation and Iraq's
government has ordered an inquiry into
the deaths protests began in early
October over demands for jobs and an end
to corruption now in a statement
Abdullah Marty said I will submit my
resignation to the House of
Representatives in order for the council
to consider its options may God protect
Iraq and its people Mohammad jammed room
joins us live from Baghdad Mohammad just
get us right up to date what's the
latest
well Peter as you mentioned the Iraqi
Prime Minister has said he is going to
be submitting his letter of resignation
but it is not yet clear exactly when
that will be this does not give a date
the statement that was that was released
it says that it will happen as soon as
possible it also goes on to say that one
of the reasons he is doing this is to
keep the country from sliding towards
violence and chaos and that this is a
response to the call for him to submit
his resignation to Parliament so that
Parliament can work on all of the
options it has now I don't know if you
can hear this but it is extremely loud
here what was a very somber mood just
about an hour ago because of the dozens
of protesters that had been killed in
both no Saudia and nisha yesterday has
turned into basically a party here in
Tahrir Square which is the epicenter of
the anti-government demonstrations in
buf dad the reason for that is the
announcement by the prime minister added
Abdul Hadi so people here who were quite
sad before activists who I've been
speaking with over the course of the
past few weeks about the developments
here who were coming up to me and
literally crying because of what
happened yesterday in the south of the
country now the same activists the same
people that were here who were so upset
well there are fireworks
going on all around us there is music
that is playing there is dancing going
on this is an extremely vibrant scene
and it really goes to show that right
now in this particular moment you have
these demonstrators that are hearing but
that who feel that this is a win for
them I will say though there are still
many here that are jaded I did hear some
people just a short while ago say okay
the Prime Minister is going to resign
and the next person who takes the office
is going to be worse than the current
one so some people wonder what exactly
is going to happen next a lot of
questions but at this particular moment
people extremely happy by this
development Peter as far as those
protests as a concern Mohammed would
they like more than just one man just
the prime minister to tender his
resignation Peter I will tell you that
what we keep hearing for people here is
that Parliament hasn't gone far enough
there's been a lot of talk the last
several weeks about electoral reform
about cutting down corruption but the
demonstrators we speak with say there
needs to be a complete overhaul of the
political system here in a talk and
that's something that's going to be
difficult and going to take time now to
that end I want to bring in a guest that
we have here today this is your nod
about how much he's with the
organization for women's freedom in Iraq
Ian our if you can join me now thank you
for being with us you know you've seen
this announcement by the prime minister
does this give you hope that now things
might start to change even if it changes
at a slow pace we feel that it's a first
step to a victory to a victory over a
corrupt a sectarian and a criminal
government the killings of hundreds of
demonstrators in the past weeks cannot
go on this feels like the victory of the
uprising people that finally the power
and the willpower of the people of the
uprising has overcome this has caused
euphoria in the demonstrating people
here in Tahrir Square and all the the
young men who are fighting on the front
lines on the bridges have heard about it
but it turns out that it's still not a
final resignation we're still waiting to
see what will happen but we feel that
this is a huge first step to prove that
the people of the uprising have proven
their willpower and that the victory
will be theirs your honor let's let's
assume that this statement means that
the prime minister would submit his
resignation effective immediately if
that were to happen if let's say
tomorrow he submits the paperwork to
Parliament what exactly is the next step
what happens from here on out the well
power of the people
the uprising people don't feel that is
enough the condition
that all the ruling political parties
have to step out of the political
formula they are not acceptable anymore
they were they all took part in the
criminal killings of the demonstrators
the people of the tiny R square will
have their say to the future government
of Iraq looking at it in a realistic way
we feel that his stepping down as a
first step but we will have to continue
the uprising until all our conditions
are met do you believe that the
protesters the thousands of
anti-government demonstrators that
continue to come out not just in Baghdad
but in the southern cities as well in
other parts of the country do you
believe that now that this announcement
has been made there will be the
willpower and incentive to continue to
come out the ones who have killed the
demonstrators were not only the Iraqi
army they were the Iranian militias and
other Islamic militias if those are
still ruling why would the demonstrators
go home all the killers all the
criminals are from those militias it's a
condition of the demonstration and
uprising that all those criminals come
to to be to be judged by the courts and
by the people of tiny R square and the
other cities it's not enough that he
throws his resignation all those
militias the ruling political parties
that cause the corruption sectarianism
and the division of the people they have
to step down and step out of Iraq yeah
now Mohamed thank you so much for
joining us today we really appreciate it
so Peter as you can hear it's a very
complicated situation here and just
because the Prime Minister has announced
that he is going to be resigning now
again we don't yet know exactly when he
is going to be submitting that paperwork
how long the process is going to take
and so that's why you are hearing what
you just heard from you're not that's
why we are hearing what we were hearing
from some of the demonstrators here yes
they take what happened in the past 15
minutes as a huge victory but they say
they are committed to can
in you to come out to showcase to the
government here that they are committed
in demonstrating and that they want to
see a complete overhaul of the political
system here in it off
Peter it seems right now I mean this
story Muhammad has just broken in the
past what 20 minutes or so that there
are now more questions than answers
because if the Prime Minister's decision
to go clearly we need to know when that
will happen will there be a domino
effect of other people tendering their
resignation and if so many people go who
replaces them that is the question of
the hour Peter if you'll remember
several weeks ago there were reports
emerging from it off that the Prime
Minister was going to be submitting his
resignation as an answer to what the
demonstrators were demanding that never
came to pass you had many officials here
saying that he was going to be stepping
aside it didn't happen then you had
reports that there had been these secret
deals made in Parliament hear various
factions parliamentary groups
essentially coming together to try to
ensure that the Prime Minister in this
particular cabinet stayed in power
because they did not believe that there
was anybody else here that could take on
this kind of huge responsibility in
order to try to mollify the protesters
and put an end to this crisis they put
out these statements they tried to tell
the protesters that they were going to
enact electoral reform that they were
cutting corruption that they were feel
pardon us again it's a pretty chaotic
scene here right now in any case we you
had all these statements coming out and
and yet the demonstrators continued to
come out despite the threats they face
despite the fact that hundreds have been
killed since the beginning of October
since these demonstrations began despite
the specter of violence despite the fact
that people were being detained at one
point you have the government here
stating that they were going to go after
anybody who'd been
and violence against the protesters the
protesters didn't believe that and so
here we are at this moment where yes
they consider this a victory they
consider this a win they consider this
to be power of the people and a
grassroots movement that has gone beyond
sectarianism that is going beyond
politics and yet they don't know what's
gonna happen next because one of the key
things you have to remember about it at
all there are no representatives of this
leaderless movement who are really
having conversations with people in
Parliament so it's very difficult for
the people on the street to know what
exactly Parliament is up to and
Parliament isn't having discussions with
them or inviting the representatives of
this movement even though there aren't
any but anybody with this movement to
come and speak with them so it's very
chaotic it's been very fluid but right
now at this hour
everybody out here believes that the
fact that the Prime Minister has
announced that he is going to step down
means that they should continue to come
out on to the streets Peter there was a
point correct me if I'm wrong here
Mohammed there was a point perhaps ten
days or two weeks ago when the protests
were ongoing when it looked and it felt
as if the government either was choosing
not to listen or it just couldn't listen
for some reason and at that point was
that a tipping point when the Prime
Minister perhaps or maybe somebody was
saying to him behind the scenes look you
are hemorrhaging political credibility
here and for the greater good of the
country not just Baghdad but the other
flashpoints the places like NASA area
that you've been mentioning in your
reporting you've got to do something and
something big
ie you've got to go
Peter when you would speak to officials
here off the record they would
acknowledge that Parliament clearly was
looking as though they were tone-deaf to
what was going on out in the streets and
I would say that yes in the last few
weeks
it does seem there was a bit of a
tipping point because when the
demonstrators initially started coming
out in early October for a variety of
reasons there was some hope that perhaps
they could start negotiations with the
government now I've been here almost a
month and in the time that I've been
here I had seen I guess I would call it
not just anger but lack of trust with
regard to the government really increase
when you speak to the anti-government
demonstrators you know time and again I
would be speaking to you and others and
we would be hearing that there was going
to be a session of Parliament in which
it was going to be discussed how
electoral reform was going to make life
better here for a Toffees how it was
going to essentially set up a system
that was more representative of the
population as a whole and oftentimes
those parliamentary sessions poram would
not be met or they would be delayed or
things that were supposed to be on the
agenda disappeared from the agenda and I
would be out here with my team at Tahrir
Square and we would go around and ask
people who'd been coming out day after
day what did you think of this and they
would say we know that Parliament is not
going to do anything we don't believe
that the Prime Minister is going to do
anything and that's why we're coming out
trying to demand his resignation and an
overhaul of the political system here
but yes clearly the more people came out
and the more anger there was because of
the violence towards demonstrators in
various cities in there a talk that
really fueled this protest moment by
that movement and it really it really
built there was a crescendo and people
here you know weekdays weekends all
hours of the day and night they have
continued to come out they are stupefied
quite frankly as to why the Internet
community is not doing more time and
again I speak to people out here who are
begging the United Nations to intervene
in some meaningful way there have been
calls by the United States and the EU
and United Nations
for early elections for their adopted
government to be doing more to ensure
that protesters here have the right to
demonstrate peacefully and yet people
that I talk to they don't think that
goes far enough and they don't think
that the world is really paying
attention to their plight and that's why
that's just one more reason why they're
angry and and so committed to coming out
Peter Mohamed's stay with us please do
do not move away from our satellite
point there in Baghdad because we just
received the very latest pictures of
people celebrating on the streets there
the news that the Iraqi Prime Minister
has said he's going to tender his
resignation as Mohammed was making the
point there does this solve the problems
that people have been reacting to up and
down Iraq over the past several weeks no
it probably doesn't I think everyone I
think is fair to say everyone would say
it does not solve the problems the
allegations of corruption no jobs people
losing money people not earning money
Iraqi security forces shooting dead more
than 40 protestors after the protesters
stormed and in effect torched that
Iranian consulate in Najaf that was one
of the flashpoint cities where people
were reacting to the situation the
ongoing situation also similar scenes
being repeated as part of the protests
in masseria but these are the latest
pictures coming to us as people digest
and absorb the news that the Iraqi Prime
Minister has said he's going to tender
his resignation at least 29 people dying
in that southern city of mass area the
Mohamed who was mentioning when troops
there opened fire on the demonstrators
they had blocked a key bridge well
before sunrise on Thursday we'll stay
with these latest pictures of
celebration and we'll go back to my
colleague Mohammed jammed room our
correspondent who's been tracking that
story for us out of the Iraqi capital so
I I guess as far as the demonstrators
are concerned Mohammed
keye worry is look if it's out with the
old it might be in with the old at some
point in the future because the Prime
Minister he's a gentleman who's been in
the orbit the arena of Iraqi politics
for several years now it's absolutely
right Peter I mean this goes beyond just
the head of the government resigning I
mean the demonstrators here they want to
see that basically the complete class of
political elites and it all gone and and
they've been demanding this for quite
some time so I you know I can only tell
you that you know we've already we've
already heard from folks here in the
last half an hour that this is good but
it doesn't go far enough and until a
time in which this mass protest movement
really senses that the government pardon
me that the government is taking their
demands seriously and really getting
past business as usual you know just
having a new prime minister that is that
is certainly not something that is going
to to satisfy them and and now that that
the Prime Minister has announced that he
is going to resign well everybody who's
out here is going to take that as an
incentive to keep coming out and keep
applying pressure on the government
Peter and it's maybe worth wrapping up
our discussion this hour mohamed just by
kind of signposting the fact that it
wasn't just baghdad it was other cities
as well it was now Surya protesters shot
dead in Chartres there were daily
protests since October so not only did
the government seem to lack the ability
to get a handle on this when it did get
a handle on it
it then kind of reacted in the wrong way
and came back too hard too often and got
up close and so personal in totally the
wrong way with those people who were
demonstrating
Peter you're mentioning and also the
let's talk about Najaf as well these are
two majority Shia cities in the country
south and yesterday you had dozens
dozens of anti-government demonstrators
killed by security forces that's
according to eyewitnesses medical
sources that we've been speaking with in
those cities when they were out
demonstrating let's talk first about
Meza Najaf of course is the is is is one
of the Shia holy cities here in a talk
and you have a majority Shia population
and you had demonstrators that about a
day and a half ago attacked the Iranian
consulate in Asia and I cannot stress
enough just how big of a deal that is
just how much of an escalation that is
because these demonstrators say that
they are tired of the outsized role and
influence that Iran plays inside of it
up and so they burned parts of the
Iranian consulate a few weeks before
that three weeks ago you had a similar
situation in another CI holy city in
Karbala in the south and which
demonstrators attacked the Iranian
consulate these were clear warning signs
to the government here to the majority
Shia government here that they needed to
do something to really show the
protesters that they were taking their
demand seriously and the protesters
didn't feel that the government was
doing that then you have what happened
in Austria you had dozens rather you had
around 20 people by our last count
according to medical sources that were
killed when they were in clashes in
front of a government building yesterday
today you have these funerals going on
this is something that not just in the
south people are reacting to here in
Baghdad as well
all the people that we speak with in
this movement they say that what makes
this movement different from prior
protests is that this is going beyond
sex and that this is going beyond
politics that this is a grassroots
movement a patriotic movement petofi's
coming together not as sunnis unless
yeah but as a talkies and that they want
a government that will treat them as
their own country that will give them
opportunity that will build a future for
them and when they see the security
forces continue to go after these
demonstrators that just it just fuels
this anger and it's why the anger has
been building and it's why the
demonstrators continue to come out
despite the threats they have faced
Peter Muhammad we had to get clarity and
context on this developing story you've
given it given us that in the past 20
minutes we'll come back to our suspect
in the next half hour or so but in the
meantime thank you so much well Abdul
Mackey's announcement comes just shortly
after Iraq's top Shia cleric Ayatollah
Ali Sistani condemned the use of lethal
force against protesters and called for
a change in leadership the Parliament
from which this current government is
drawn is asked to reconsider its choice
in this regard and to act according to e
Rock's interest and preserve the blood
of its children to prevent the country
from slipping into violence chaos and
destruction we confirm again that
attacks against peaceful protesters are
forbidden as well as then being
prevented from having the right to
demand reforms we also confirm that
attacking private and public property is
forbidden and that property should not
be left to be attacked by infiltrators
and their lives